welcome to this blitz game against HSK
fmhs k this Marty t keinen or something
Macotakara I'm almost right okay let's
see Kings Indian yep let's play the
classical with 92 ahead to excellent two
or three excellent opening results with
that recently I spoiled one very nice
game with them bed time management but
but stood was a nice annoyed some
position young 97 I think they go we
wanted before him I only don't I think
King age 8 and this is how Kasparov
plated yeah he does that I how does wide
play now I think there was Bishop d3 in
some lines but I cannot really remember
that correctly Quincy to also looks like
me let's let's do that maybe this is an
idea to play a quick c5 I'm really
making it up as I go along him c5 hmmm
come on yeah based on the on the
assumption that oh that is surprising
okay I have to take anyway based on the
assumption that he can never do that
because of the the pressure that white
will get but maybe he's right maybe he's
right here because I'm obviously I
cannot plain a bishop a three after
night takes um I can play might be five
though
on take 95 and it's also move b6 Bishop
a three yeah ok let's see that I'm not
getting hopelessly behind timewise yeah
white has sacrificed the pawn but in the
process he has opened the the queenside
completely so it should be a decent
compensation so I'm very complicated
though um yeah I don't know should black
play move like queen e seven and two to
cover that but I have night be three
okay then he might take on a three
giving up the exchange after queen is
seven I also have the capture maybe on
c5 just seemed just simple play ok does
that okay well yeah it can take c5 and
tick well let's do that first and now
take c-5m does this must be good really
or not attacking c seven e4 is still
hanging okay that's this counter play
based on the fact that those two pieces
are hanging
so Luke the one I guess maybe you can go
III that I can take with the Queen as
well Bishop h6 maybe that one okay
interesting I am to a six
oopsie form yeah it's something we're
having some time would be would be nice
this is look just look just look kind of
misplaced
yeah I guess Roxy too
I can take on c7 though I mean I really
can and that that's really excellent for
white I guess it is just very
complicated okay I'm taking an order
taking on edge was a bit meek I want
after the rookie move I just take Knight
takes e4 and this is nice I have them
more active position definitely and he's
got light squared weaknesses all along
Queen takes b5 is just for the tempos
that I can win the tempo on the rook it
also doesn't have any super great
squares yeah our night XD form let's not
spend an hour on that yeah night to e6
this is this is where this piece wants
to go another means that sometimes this
interesting is d6 opening up the bishop
but this is something that should be
time carefully I otherwise I might help
him it's very difficult for black to
play this position night coming to e6
I could have gone to g 4g 5 i'm not sure
if it is if it is better on basically
the same thing okay you can put the
Queen on d6 and sort of try to hang on
it doesn't look good but it's not so
clear how I'm how I'm progressing that's
not so clear actually 96 rupee aid
Quincy six slot that's not totally clear
I don't want to trade Queens but I don't
don't see don't see a better solution at
the moment what I retain is this
pressure on c7 it's not much it's not
much here I'm right that probably did
something wrong I'm not quite sure what
but that's it's not not an ideal
scenario hmm I am maybe I have looked
the aid actually black takes takes rook
b6 look the eight on night 98 always
doing that okay would be aight i guess
rookie one is trying to use his his back
rank
turn will be six it's not clear many
does escape them indeed okay cannot look
at the bank right back rank all of the
time I'm not sure g3 respect I am now
Kim hard to say i was i'm thinking of
just taking on d6 and play rugby 6 this
kind of thing group b 6 it keeps it
keeps an advantage not sure if it is the
best one probably not
it's difficult to defend night here now
I can play shoved III actually check I
didn't that it was stupid eft was
hanging with with the tempo Liam time
morning I wanted to know I can I have to
play that here anyway I didn't I didn't
hangs with the tempo I thought that this
was just winning which is not the case I
mean it's very nice for wide but it's
not winning yeah okay I will win this
windows on time check black forfeits on
time yeah it probably was according to
how the position was but struggled a
little bit there yeah that set is an
interesting interesting position here
he's an taking this pawn and says okay
show me I mean white has definite
compensation but it's um it is a very
difficult to play position yeah here
would be six that the def definitely
makes sense now I went TM yeah I don't
know what you should do night it took he
I am which really am gives up any hope
for a good structure the compounds to
sacrifice the exchange and tea and then
take now that's interesting d 5 is maybe
up for the taking yeah stockfish gives
black a slight advantage here how many
points does he have two pawns no it's
it's ok for black maybe Bishop e3 wasn't
the great greatest move ever then but ok
bone in blitz he took took and here ok
ok to what lengths that's good for black
so the computer wants me to take here
with an equal position ok and this was a
mistake it seems
yeah bishop age six this is something
that I've feared during the game didn't
really know what to do then to be honest
yeah Queen Queen see 30 I was was my
idea but this is not look idea Joe it
all is all very very complicated but
good food like there are some funny
points I mean this is one of them like
has this move and here i guess i'm
starting to really have a good position
yeah plus one about plus one okay oh
look a oneness our strongest i didn't
think about it at the hunch that there's
something but ok i had to had to play
something in time yeah interesting him
this is check this is not not working at
all which is not so so easy to see yeah
i mean with time everything's nice but
yeah this is a just got quite nice yeah
I didn't see any of that and here this
is this is also known nice for me
drinking age seven this was keeping an
edge and now queen bee five is better
but this keeps a big advantage as well
so okay I didn't play it too badly
around here you had huge time issues
anyway okay well thanks for watching